it gets to my attention that you started
a talk show true or not true i did
jealous
i've always loved to have one of those
so i started uh ms tv on monday night
raws uh on usa and uh miss tv it's not
like this because see your audience no
matter what whether a good joke or a bad
joke they're gonna laugh you walked out
here you walked out here today
oh you're so terrific
that's a discerning crowd they they
leave me cold when i don't know oh no no
no no on the other hand when i go out
there when i go out there and i say a
bad joke they boo me and then chant you
suck for three minutes
sometimes when i introduce a guest they
boo the guest this is that's my uh
sounds fantastic how about this my set
gets trashed at least once a month you
smash no you're set people smash my set
they rip apart everything they get into
fights it's it's amazing no is who's
fighting who is it the audience charging
the stage enough my guests fight each
other sometimes i fight my guests
this these are things you need to do
conan fighting equals ratings i love
that i would love to i mean right now i
would really love to fight mike you
don't want to fight me though you don't
want to fight me cody
look at it
[Applause]
you guys better be very careful who
you're chanting for all right i'm a wwe
superstar i'm a trained professional if
you want to fight you bring johnny back
out here and well battle the nerds
it's on tbs isn't it it's that t-shirt
on tv very good thank you very good on
this energy
let me quickly get to this we're out of
time
my movie i'm gonna get uh
29 april 7th marine comes out
march
[Applause]
hey vince mcmahon vince mcmahon will be
very upset if i don't promote uh
wrestlemania
29
at red light stadium april 7th get it
it's on pay-per-view okay april 7th
wrestlemania 29 will air on pay-per-view
and also
i want to make sure i mentioned the
marine three the home front
clip
yes stop yelling at me i'm excited i
want to see the clip what's that
clip yeah go to the clip go to the clip
stop right there
he can't take that shot
but i can
[Music]
[Applause]
wait a minute yeah i thought you were
going to fight him no who needs a fight
i got a gun in my hand
fight him and shoot the guy
and the premise here is that they take
your daughter is that right no my my
sister i have two sisters and uh one of
them gets kidnapped by a terrorist
militia group headed by neil mcdonough
the great neil mcdonough who is famed
for so many things when i report
justified and so
my question is brain comes out why do
they always steal the sister or the
sibling of the biggest badass
why don't you ask like neil mcdonough or
his character why he stole my sister but
you don't want to steal my sister i'm a
marine yeah
what do you mean yeah oh no i'm not i'm
jake carter usmc son all right okay
i'm a method actor i'm a message